bonjour le rythme très bon jour aux
auditeurs de radio martinique conseil
exécutif en charge du transport merci
d'être avec nous à à trois heures de la
mise un service à blanc du fameux tcsp
le transport en commun en site propre
qui verra ses quatorze bus à haut niveau
de service enfin enfin rouler et pour
cela il aura fallu louis boutrin qu'il y
ait un risque de voir l'europe se fâcher
car l'argent investi n'aura pas été
utilisé comme il le faut pour qu'on en
arrive là monsieur le ton la charge de
la preuve incombe à celui qui diffuse
l'information vous diffuser une
information sans détenir les preuves de
vos impressions
oui mais votre confrère n'a pas bougé
une question il a été affirmatif sur le
site de martine première donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire je le refais nous
n'avons reçu aucune réaction
aucune lettre de la commission
européenne ce niveau de la commission
européenne nous demandant de rembourser
les 80 millions 6 au 31 mars le dissès
mélodies mer les talents possède
aujourd'hui brusquement dans un dossier
qui n'arrêtait pas d'être reporté d'être
repoussée au grand dam des martiniquais
qui attendent de pouvoir circuler
librement dans ce pays les raisons sont
multiples première raison faut savoir
que quand alfred marie jeanne la liste
conduite par alfred marie-jeanne gagnent
les élections du 13 décembre 2015 le
tcsp était loin d'être opérationnel
il a fallu terminer les travaux livrer
l'ouvragé
c'est ce que nous avons fait et puis il
ya une raison essentielle
nous sommes bien loin du projet initial
qui est un projet de tramway qui coûtait
248 millions d'euros et nous sommes
retrouvés avec le projet de bus à haut
niveau de service de la multinationale
26 qui a coûté la bagatelle de 410
millions d'euros
alors tout cela ça a rallongé les délais
autre raison essentielle c'est que quand
nous arrivons le groupe de d'alfred
marie-jeanne arrive à la majorité nous
avons été exclus du syndicat mixte du
tcs mais nous n'avions pas la majorité
va pas refaire tout l'historique de ce
même si long mais il ya des raisons
objectives comme aujourd'hui
vendredi permettez 30 secondes il faut
clarifier les choses et quand le
président de la ctm monsieur marie
jeanne a effectivement compris qu'il
fallait faire démarrer ce tcsp
il a pris une douche fait prendre par la
solide matinée qu'une délibération pour
prolonger l'habilitation transport et
c'est sous le fondement de la bile de
l'habilitation transport qu'il a créé un
outil qui est l'établissement public
véritable autorité organisatrice de
transport qui s'est substitué à toutes
les autorités organisatrices y compris à
la casse elle c'est ce qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui
et ce sera aussi l'avant garde
j'applaudirais vous dire c'est une
hausse énorme héritage de sauveur du soc
teaser martinique ce qui explique
monsieur viol ton que c'est un qualité
de président un noeud martin transport
de l'établissement public qu'il va
effectivement bien lancé le 17 mai à 11h
serions très pratique maintenant on a eu
des dates et plus farfelue car jamais
respecté tout son équipe précédente ou
de la vôtre pour la mise en service de
ce thé csp il a aujourd'hui la mise en
blanc les martiniquais pourront
emprunter ce tcsp à partir de quand est
ce que vous êtes en mesure de nous le
dire ce matin ça fonctionnera à partir
de quand c'est à l'issue de la période
de test qui est prévu deux mois une
période qui est nécessaire pour vérifier
ajuster le fonctionnement de l'ensemble
du système
tant sur le plan sécuritaire le plan
technique que lorsqu à fixer et
effectivement dans deux mois à peu près
de moi c'est très proche
hautmont nous parlons vous savez déjà
combien ça coûtera le billet le prix du
ticket mensuel par exemple le prix du
billet sera aux environs de 1 euro 20
pour le trajet est de 2 euros 30 pour un
aller road show c'est un billet qui sera
valable pour une heure de temps avec une
correspondance possible sur les taxis qu
est également jeunes au transport
maritime c'est ce qu'avait déjà dans la
délégation s'est comblé entrons dans les
détails si vous le permettez vous
goûterez les détails c'est là justement
se cache le diable 7 sp ne sera un
succès que si
il paraît évident et facile à utiliser
je sors de sainte luce je gare ma
voiture ou et cela me coûtera combien
pour laisser ma voiture au parking est
ce que ça va s'ajouter au prix du ticket
de transport alors l'autorité
organisatrice unique martin phospore si
son conseil d'administration qui va
déterminer la tarification à la fois du
parking à la fois du trajet nous avons
déjà des indicateurs mais la période
test nous permettra encore d'affiner
tout cela on en réflexion les
interconnexions je pars de la pointe
simon je m'arrête dans une station sur
un des ponts je me rends comme à mon
bureau par exemple à chateauboeuf ou ou
si je travaille à la sécu elle a pas de
griffes aussi je encore je joue au
tennis à l'as ptt comment ça se passe
alors vous avez bien compris
qu'aujourd'hui le tcsp n'est qu'un
maillon d'une chaîne de déplacement et
qu' il faut au delà du tcsp mettre en
place une véritable organisation basée
au sport avec missy maintenant si si
martinique transport c'est-à-dire lors
les établissements publics non seulement
nous y travaillons mais nous sommes en
train de finaliser ce projet
d'organisation globale sur tout le
territoire parce que des entreprises
travaillent déjà à demander à leur
direction de mettre sur pied des
navettes car craignant de se retrouver
sur le pont et ne sachant pas comment se
rendre au bureau et puis la plaque à
tomber oui le tcsp
c'est le lac se sent trahie mais à
partir le tcsp ne va pas de pénétrer
dans les quartiers dont il faut une
desserte fine des quartiers à partie
d'une réorganisation du transport urbain
et périurbain
c'est ce que mettra en place
l'établissement public de transport
martin aux transports les chauffeurs de
taxi de place on y revient quelques
secondes
que leur dites-vous ce matin oui ou non
définitivement pourront-ils utiliser ses
couleurs du tcsp
là encore la période test va nous
permettre de déterminer la fréquence
il est prévu un bus à haut niveau de
service sous l' axe central toutes les
dix minutes
si maintenant on fait entrer des taxis
de place nous l'envisageons ça va si ça
se sait si tout à fait envisageable mais
dans cette hypothèse il y aura une
incidence ça va impacter le
fonctionnement des feux
donc interrompre la circulation normale
donc voit qu'elle sera donc ça non donc
c'est non définitivement le riz sommes
venus vous nous ne sommes pas des
techniciens
il y à des techniciens retenir encore ce
feuilleton ce n'est pas un combat commun
en site propre
mais c'est le site web réservé aux
touristes à l'envol services a nommé
retenir qu'on vise plutôt une demande
récurrente des taxis place dont nous
intégrons cette demande nous l'analysons
et nous verrons effectivement quelles
suites à donner mais nous ne pouvons pas
décider de manière autoritaire des
cartes essaie d'intégrer ses quartiers
dans le cadre dans la feuille de route
de ce modèle en site propre dans
l'arrêté dans l'arrêté pris il est prévu
exclusivement le bus à haut niveau de
service fin du feuilleton
les chauffeurs de taxi c'est non on peut
passer à peu passer une autre question
si vous voulez louis boutrin on a connu
le port de commerce on a connu des
tentatives de blocage ou la sarako moins
de pression pour tel ou tel corps de
métier ce tracé du tcsp comment garantir
qui sera sécurisé et sanctuariser car si
à chaque difficulté on le bloquer mais
ça ira très vite personne paris prix
mais celle incitation à la rébellion que
vous faites là ce match oppose deux
questions très pratiques à écouter parce
que moi j'ai le pays
j'ai simplement envie de savoir voyager
à jour tous les jours à montreuil tout
simplement vous avez l'habitude
l'occasion de notes de voyage à travers
le monde effectivement si un mouvement
de grève y compris dans les grandes
villes vous voyez que ça va perturber le
bon fonctionnement et le déplacement à
de développement sans transport effet
lance justement on arrive un point qui
est essentielle parce que nous n'avons
pas droit à l'erreur en me suis vu le
temps et c'est pour ça qu'on nous disons
que une bonne partie du mieux-être des
martiniquais et surtout des entreprises
et un en ce moment rattaché au succès de
cette entreprise qui d entreprise
colossale décès pousse la queue en
responsabilité nous allons mettre en
place ce tcsp qui n'est qu'un maillon
d'une chaîne succès ici c'est simple et
rapide si efficace c'est une chaîne de
déplacement à travers un schéma global
de déplacements sécurisés nous avons
mutualisé sens sans que ce soit un appel
à la rébellion
ce sera sécurisé ce sera centralisé et
ouvrira à la fin de cette période de
test
quelle sera effectivement les temps de
passage et qu'est ce cas la fréquence la
vitesse commerciale
tout cela c'est prévu harnes a pris
tellement de retard sur ce tcsp et il a
jurieux de vous poser des questions par
exemple sur des extensions de ce tcsp
vers le nord caraïbes vers le nord
atlantique vers le sud alors les
extensions sont d'ores et déjà prévues à
travers un certain nombre d'études
notamment vers le nord caraïbe au niveau
de ravine tout ça et de l'université
prévues également dans le centre
atlantique au niveau du robert trinité
et vers le sud au niveau de rivière
salée
c'est là encore un véritable diagnostic
que nous devons mettre en place pour
mesurer la pertinence de ces extensions
parce que ça aura un coût il faut bien
se dire aujourd'hui que la réflexion et
le global ce n'est pas seulement une
question de mettre des infrastructures
il y a à la question foncière qui va
s'opposer avec l'organisation de
parkings relais
il y a également d'autres points
importants ce la desserte des quartiers
non vous comprenez bien que on a dans
une nouvelle ère nous sommes bien loin
d'une simple question des frasques
rupture il s'agit pour la martinique
aujourd'hui de relever le défi de la
mobilité et des déplacements en oui non
oui on a la réponse
cergy midi qui ne viendra pas craignant
un trou de manoeuvre pour vous qui le la
mise en service se sert de ce tcsp avec
du retard
qu'est ce que vous lui dites il a tort
de ne pas venir ce matin ses recherches
des de chimie a fait du tcsp un outil de
propagande politique donc je me
permettrai pas de commenter ces
commentaires merci louis boutrin
rappelle que vous êtes conseiller
exécutif en charge des transports merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci a reçu à
trois heures de la mise en service de ce
tcsp bonne journée
[Musique]